الطاوله التي جلسا الى جهه واحده منها
للسنوات انقلبت والوساطه باتت مطلوبه لوعد
المواجهه المسلحه بينهما في مهد العاصمه
بعد اربعه ايام على انزلاق رجلين الحكم
العسكري في السودان الى مستنقع القتال
سيناريوهات ثلاثه محتمله رسمت لمستقبل
المواجهه بين قائد القوات المسلحه ونائبه
السيناريو الاول ذهب الى حرب شوارع طويله
تنحصر في العاصمه مع محاوله كل طرف فيها
حسم المعركه لمصلحته لكنه ينتهي بانتشار
قوات الجيش السوداني في كافه المناطق
والاحياء فاعتماد الجيش استراتيجيه
استنزاف الموارد وتفوقه من ناحيه المعدات
العسكريه والطائرات قد يكون نقطه الفصل
على ارض المعركه حيث ستفقد قوات الدعم
السريع ذات التسليح الخفيف والمتوسط مؤنها
من وقود وذخيره وغذاء خلال ثلاثه ايام من
الاشتباك المتواصل اول السيناريوهات رجح
انسحاب احمدتي تكتيكيا الى دارفور في حال
حوصره من الجيش ليتظلل بقواته المتمرده
مجردا من اي مناصبه او مشاركه بالمشهد
السياسي الا في حال التسويه اما السيناريو
الثاني فيتمثل بوقف لاطلاق النار بعد
وسطات عربيه وغربيه يليه بدء عمليه
التفاوض والمحاكمات العسكريه لينتهي بدمج
قوه الدعم السريع المتبقيه مع الجيش
ويشمل السيناريو الثالث وقف اطلاق النار
وعوده الجميع للتسويه وهنا الاحتمال
المطروح عدم وجود قوات الدعم السريع كطرف
رئيسيا في العمليه التفاوضيه والذهاب
لفتره انتقاليه جديده تهيئ للانتخابات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات